tout d'abord je dois dire que moi j'ai
pas de playback
moi je plais où je plais pas et pis
c'est tout mais bon et comme a dit
michel briquet dans notre émission vous
pouvez prendre tous les risques mais
choisit c'est quand même la sécurité
alors je me mouille pas j'ai choisi la
sécurité
qu'est ce qui me gêne aussi les clés de
ma loge s'appelle sadek les dénoncer une
borne kilométrique à déférer donc
dernièrement j'ai vu une émission à la
télévision qui m'a beaucoup intéressé
c'était l'année dernière
sir la vie des mozart et ça m'a donné
l'envi de lire sa biographie
c'est comme ça que je me suis aperçu que
nous avons des points communs avec
mozart par exemple consomme biologiste
écrit que lee moore est rare chez les
génies ma modestie m'oblige à penser que
je n'ai donc pas d'humour
ou alors que je suis un des rares à
avoir les deux et comme elle écrite et
mozart ravel 2 est un premier point
commun
deuxième point commun attaquant mozart
composer son premier livre est et moi
aussi à 4 ans j'ouvrais mon premier
livret à la caisse d'epargne troisième
point commun avec moyens avec mozart
parce qu'avec moïse aussi j'ai des
points communs
quand il est monté sur le mont sinaï a
mené 3000 avant jc
pour aller chercher les dix
commandements il est resté là au 40
jours après le dixième bon et justement
c'est tout et l'éternel répondre en déjà
ça si ça se vende bien j'en écrirai
d'autres mais la différence avec moïse
celui réservé la parole divine
il avait quatre ans m tandis que moi
j'écris la parole elle n'est peut-être
pas divine
mais devinez combien ils gagnent
à être reconnue donc troisième point
commun avec mozart mozart à 25 ans était
au sommet de son génie et c'est là que
nos chemins divergent
parce que moi à 25 ans je dois
reconnaître que la source volcanique qui
grondait sous le sommet des mâts calotte
crânienne ne trouvait pas la sortie
j'ai reconnaît humblement que je suis
resté longtemps en bouche et je devrais
pas le débouché
et un jour hôpitaux une nuit comme
beethoven qu'il ait entendu bon pompon
j'ai entendu pop opecst
je me suis dit c'est un signe et j'ai
ouvert les yeux et c'est là que j'ai
aperçu j'ai vu la vierge comme je veux
boire je me suis dit c'est pas possible
il s'est trompé d'appartement touché son
mari vous c'est pour ça que je n'ai
jamais dit à personne je savais qu'on me
croirait pas et elle m'a paris elle m'a
dit pape et que le monde est triste
fais moi rire que lui dis avec quoi
señorita moi c'est la mère du seigneur
bon à l'enseigné rita
et elle m'a tendu un stylo un diplôme
hors garantie 3 ans elle m'a dit écrit
et la disparue sans jamais réparé et
pourtant je les appelais plusieurs fois
mais faudrait des riches pour les stylos
et alors dernier point avec cauet mozart
qui a écrit une sonate en aluminium en
élite et liminaire intitulé les marchés
aux tirs et mois parallèlement à sa
musique j'ai écrit une sonate ans dans
un poème en vrac intitulé les marchés
aux tic
si vous voulez je peux vous enchanter un
morceau il m'aurait fallu un pianiste
pour ma compagne et mon frère vous savez
j'ai demandé au conservatoire j'ai
demandé un bon pianiste ils m'ont
proposé un premier prix alors je leur ai
dit votre dernier prix c'est combien cod
pris un pianiste impérial mais changer
tout ça
gérez vous chanter la vie des marchés
mon ami le vieux machos les caleçons
molletonnés qui va de ville en village
si la place et des marchés près de lui
il ya les bouquinistes et la mercière
boucher et la jolie petite playlist et à
l'axone des méditerranée et je vois
encore ces baratineurs m'attendre à
monter et à démonter à déballer sa voix
comines et crécelles et bouffant des
légumes approché tout chez moi ça ce
n'est pas de la gnognotte et approcher
choisissent essayer c'est l'adopter
c'est quand il fait pour qu'on se sent
bien dans les tissus que la firme lui
vous piquez pas les kits cetera et
cetera
où est la brique et où les jolies piano
c'est pour moi qui voulais blesser lula
ohlala les touches sont toutes noires
dit dont il a besoin d'aller chez le
dentiste
oui pour faire un détartrage mathias
avait donné une idée si j'ai encore une
minute géant go et mildt je vais vous
jouez là je vais vous la jouer à les
marchés aux tic à la russe seulement je
dois vous prévenir que si vous entendez
des fausses notes ne les croyez pas
saint-céré de la propagande anti
soviétique et vous demande juste une
minute les temps de faire la mise au
point qu avec mes musiciens
alors écoutez moi bien vous êtes dix
doigts il ya 85 note
il y en aura pour tout le monde
alors ne vous montez pas les anciens les
autres
comment s'est allégé tôt et finissent et
très tôt et c'est là que vous allez voir
que nos points communs serré joint avec
mozart parce que si c'est vrai que la
musique adoucit les makes il est ici
aussi adoucir les makes parce que mozart
vous réchauffe l'homme par la musique
mais moi j'ai vous réchauffe les qui
parle dans le temps
non
moi je voudrais bien rencontrer
l'ingénieur qui a eu l'idée est géniale
décret des pistes cyclables à paris
les fameuses bandelettes j'aurai des
mots à lui dire parce que ces rythmes
bien passé les bandelettes paix côté
trottoir
vous avez les couloirs réservés aux
autobus et aux taxis aux milliers vous
avez les autos entre les deux les vélos
ip plis s'échapper tôt ou tard et
cyclistes ou les coince il est pris en
sandwich
il est petit alors messieurs les
écologistes ne comptez pas sur moi pour
vous suivre si ces voix là les vélos oui
les pièges à cons non
croyez moi qui a paris ils voient bien
roulé en auto est bon je voudrais bien
de pouvoir mais stationnés quelque part
regardez-moi ça y'a pas une place paypal
est stationnée dans un parking non
bricolo misé 10 principes préfet
risquaient une contravention
ah ben voilà il omet c'est un passage
clouté pompiers n'ont pas besoin des
trois mètres pour traverser les
pitchouns donc à passer un deal un jean
blanc lâche qu'est-ce qui fait sourire
au celi là comment j'ai failli vous
écraser et alors vous voyez pas clé mais
plus c'est pas un trottoir en commun
c'est un passage clouté et bae systems
ont marché sur les clous pas si ma
voisine
non mais vous avez vu cette arrogance
j'aurais fils écrasé comme une pinède et
au lieu de ça j'ai dit stop larry et il
en profite pour m'engueuler saleté des
piétons bas non mais sans blague pas des
sauvages thème et non pas me laisser
marcher sur les pieds moi non pierre
kamé patrie quand vous sortez de chez
vous lui amène au volant parce que
j'avais déjà des fois qu'on essaie de
l'approcher
ça y est voilà une aubergine et à 500
voitures en stationnement
vous allez voir que c'est la mienne qui
l'intéressent et bonjour madame
aubergines et madame hadja comment il
faut pas rester là à bâle ont mal géré
ce palace et c'est ma voiture
moi je les communs c'est pas une raison
pour stationner sur les clous et mais
c'est ce que j'aime et il lui dit mais
il était petit c'est dj bakhat indymac
j'ai pour lui dire j va par là elle y va
quand même ça y est ré son chéquier
ma femme c'est pareil pour un oui pour
un non et sur deux jours en turquie
et c'est moi qui paye savez que vous
ressemblez alice sapritch vous est pas
lisse à bridge et comprend toujours les
bdt cathérine d'élèves à on vous l'a
déjà dit il vous voyez que je baratine
pas mais si je peux me permettre un
petit conseil vous avez des jo lisieux
c'est dommage de les cacher pas des
grosses lunettes
pourquoi vous mettez pas plus tôt à la
place et vous savez des petits pois et
des lentilles mais vous êtes gentille je
n'ai pu me dites vous elle est charmante
et bien avec les paniers toujours moyen
de s'entendre
sauf qu'avec la mienne y'a rien à faire
c'est une santé bon je voudrais bien
pouvoir traverser moi vous me laissez
passer ou non il ya des masseurs y en a
pas un qui va s'arrêter je me demande à
quoi ça sert des maîtres de passage
caoutchouté réservé aux piétons
personnes les respecte on nous chasse
comme des canards sauvages
bon alors oui sinon je serais encore là
demain au logis mais son coup de sang
n'arriverait jamais vivant de votre côté
comment madame je vous prennent les bras
pourquoi fait on ne se connaît pas
eh ben on traverse et je n'arrive déjà
pas à traverser moi même vous voyez vous
m j'suis pas un porte-bagages
bon allez montez et rennais membres à
vous mêler rendrait dès votre côté alors
chacun pour soi et dieu pour moi à la
ville
on les saletés de m'aider mais ces
débats
encore un allemand y viennent gisquet
donnery écraser nos fils et nos
compagnes
comment messier pour aller aux invalides
et bah vous traversez il vous coupe les
pattes et vouziers aux invalides
et bonjour madame les braises je suis
bien dans les films autant rapport
clément 1 a autant en emporte bas qui
l'emportent ou qui rapporte le principal
c'est qu'on passe un bon moment parce
que la dernière fois qu'on la vie
c'était en plein air est l'écrin s'est
envolé avant la fin allons tenir à la
netiquette des places s'il vous plaît
comment où est la deuxième personne est
dans la voilà c'est mon cher goliath
rassurez vous il est très propre ni pont
ni pis ni pin s est fait pipi là où on
lui dit faire passer le protégea il fera
des sous alors tenez voilà les
pourboires garder garder là monnaie
allons nous asseoir à nous asseoir
pardon mais si on ne vous dérangent et
surtout pas olala je vous ai monté sur
les pieds et à ccc de votre dame
excusez moi madame je me suis trompé des
pieds à la mets toi là goliath
aulas
j'arrête de faire la gaine belle et le
clochard
on l'a déjà vie trois fois le cinéma ce
n'est pas fait pour les chiens
comment madame je suis assis si votre
manteau ça me dérange pas et il va
croatie et ben les délais silva fois ci
c'est qu'on vous a vendue de la saleté
ténèbres la maca caleçons molletonnés
garantie infroissable goliath lui
l'armée pas une embellie mais quand même
ça sentir anti viol et pourtant c'est un
malin mais je ne peux pas les premiers
cinq minutes sans qu'on vienne me
fourrer le nez dans ses affaires
l'autre fois c'était un pharmacien un
dalmatien un molosse heureusement il
était mise et les relais profité pour
les bottés liquide il a filé sans
demander les restes un goliath
comment baissier de quelle race il est
il est française autant que vous ne
faites pas de père en fils mais sa mère
un gratin dauphinois ce griffon de
pékinois a été croisée par surprise par
un bouledogue japonaise un kamikaze
comme dans la guerre du feu sa famille
l'a guéri fait quand elle ses pages au
bord de la rivière ou se laver manger
mais la mpa hilton s'est passé le savons
pas par qui qui est là pour la partie
s'était même pas interdit au moins de 13
ans alors décroché il est à moi comme
mon petit neveu d'un évent m'a demandé
ton temps qu'est ce qui lui a fait à la
dame les messieurs heureusement je n'ai
pas perdu mon sang-froid
je lui ai rien répondu il ya des fois
faut savoir parler aux enfants 1
alors pour revenir à mon chien il a pris
la tête à son père et les restes à sa
mère personne n'est pas fait et on
appelle ça un chiffre bas rhin chinois
comme ça se prononce comme me le dis
donc toi petit voyou
tu as fini délicat des images commencent
à celui qu'a commencé il grimace passé
sa tête qu'il est comme ça c'est pas
beau de se moquer ni les caresser pas
vous bon sang vous voyez pas que ça lui
plaît pas je caresse par votre femme
moineaux
ce sera une femme c'est un chien vous
voulez savez que c'est un chien mais lui
est ce qu'il laissait ça y est en valeur
d 1 mètre 90 il faut qu'ils se mettent
juste devant goliath est bien moins
chihuahua ivoiriens on va l'entendre il
a payé sa place comme tout le monde
c'est ben oui moi si c'est après vous
qu'il en a non non il mord prime au
point haut débit prévient
que vous avez trois minutes pour changer
des places ne faut pas se fier à
l'apparence d'un flair des chiens
policiers aux mondiaux il ya une dame
l'a laissé tomber sa broche en or massif
et beurre il a avalé qui est pour
l'emmener chez les métairies né voulait
qu'on lui fasse ouvrir les banques je
dirais d'îlots mon chien c'est pas une
tuerie va pas les casser pour vous faire
plaisir non il médite y en a pour 1
million jeudi beau c'est de l'argent
placé on n'est pas des sauvages même
où
si mon papa mais voyez lui qui me disait
toujours si j'étais en france il ya des
choses que j'aimerais faire aller
visiter la grande synagogue de
notre-dame de paris et dîner chez
maxim's ne va pas paraître je suis chez
maxim's et il est mon invité titre
posthume mettrait d'hôtel
pour commencer vous allez nous donner ne
pas donner un bon c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on va chez maxim's non pli est
là vous allez nous donner et comment si
j'attends quelqu'un une auge attend
personnes j'ai des jeunes avec moi-même
vont prendre la même chose
alors vous allez nous donner in et un
bal des champignons et non attendez
démarquer page et me méfie des
champignons ça me rappelle que j'ai un
ami qu'il est mort deux jours après
l'avoir mangé des champignons dans la
marmite et phalloïde moyon notre et
chose araignées des mérous la santé des
bêtes ohlala ou quand je pense que ça
existe des araignées comme ça dans la
mer avec des patrons rouge et bélie gens
comme les jambes de ma concierge
ah bah voilà ça ça me plaît vous allez
me donner in et saumon fumé avec
supplément
qu'est ce que vous en donnez comme
supplément un as et en supplément des
prix c'est pourquoi il est en supplément
des prix parce qu'il vient d'où des
scandinavie si je comprends bien c'est
moi qui les paye son voyage il n'y a pas
un qui vient des plis près non parce que
les poissons qui viennent de loin j'ai
mes filles
il arrive souvent fatigués par les
voyages y en a pas mal et sait pas
comment ça s'appelle la bestiole avec
les pinces là que ça commence avec un
cas et pas par la crise est là la cré vi
j'en passe entre 10 as et la roma à
l'américain boeing et le mollah omar à
l'américain ben voila je vois comme ça
et on verra au fur à mesure j'ai dit on
verra offir masi f qui fit comprendre
les princesses et du vin
j'ai pris la roue main parce que y'a pas
des prix on dirait bien pourrait nous
offrir l'apéritif quand même à ce prix
là nous n'est pas des sauvages tout même
et bonjour monsieur vous êtes coin son
métier et il n'y a pas de sot métier et
moi je suis cantonniers est assez pour
les vins rabot je croyais que des
problèmes à cloud saas et 10 homélie bon
écoute et aujourd'hui je vais pas boire
les vins des métiers tout le monde je
vais un vin de qualité très supérieure
je regarde pas à la dépense mais je vais
le meilleur et le moins cher
alors qu'est ce que vous allez me donner
des bons dans les grands bordeaux
d'accord dernière page allons-y
qu'est ce que je lis la chaffoteaux et
maury à château de pouilly
avant j'aurais dû prendre mes lunettes
et la chatonnay dis pas tiens il fait
dans les vins aussi
la carafe d'eau est gratuite
bon on va déjà la prendre la carafe
d'eau est alors pour colorer un plus
écoutez moi je me connais pas mais je
vous fais confiance je ne connais pas
qu'est ce que vous allez me proposer les
bons et un mouton rothschild voilà une
bonne idée oui comment
si je les préfère dans une coin dans une
grande tv et non pas dans une grande si
bête et donne dans une petite bouteille
ça c'est plus un petit quart à pau
comment vous en avez est millésimé 1900
combien 1929 il vous en reste en cours
dès cette époque
moi c'est pareil dit la mairesse des
anciens modèles des caleçons molletonnés
j'arrive pas à les liquider et vous
laissons le dire combien 1500 francs 15
france fhf 3500 nouveaux cent cinquante
mille points vous êtes sûr que c'est pas
les taux longs cent cinquante mille
points pour une bouteille de vin ya des
quoi sert et que dire des pistes pendant
dix jours 1 c'est un coup à vous donner
la prostate ça
faites la carte bleue ici fait pas
l'accabler de la carte orange bon écoute
et amener mois déjà la casa dos et puis
on va réfléchir si j'ai encore soif on
va apprendre les bains voilà ça me
rappelle quand gestuelle avec mon père
dans une et grands le restaurant qu'est
ce qui va me regarder comme un fou je
vous parle pas vous je me parle à moi et
on était allé dans un grand restaurant
des deux garçons il avait aussi un peu
de vin il attendait derrière et mon père
est dit qu'est ce qu'ils attendent
derrière moi avec la bouteille à la main
là il m'a versé un fond de verre il faut
pas qu'il va mêler compté pour environ
thiennot à voilà que les homards à
l'américain la banale et voilà voilà
avaya piste car cascades et aux marques
non j'ai dit la prise des casques et des
romains qu'est ce qu'il est arrivé lé
tout casser il a fait un atterrissage
forcé génome à l'américain qu'il
appelait l anglaise avant d'arriver dans
mon assiette la main qui pense la bauma
ça dépend ce que j'ai payé pour les
dépenses non comment ils se sont bâties
dans les viviers et ben alors apportez
moi le vainqueur par les vaincus bon
sens